hi my name is uh brett goldsmith
i'm the cto and co-founder of cardea and
today i'm going to talk to you about
what cardea is doing to help change
how the world conducts biology
so uh we think about biology um
in a similar way to how we think about
all the other technology that's out
there in the world
and when we think about uh technology
the thing that that comes up
the most is the power of digital
networks uh
digital networks are are critical to how
we live today
particularly right now in the middle of
the covet 19 crisis
they're how we communicate instantly and
globally
around the world they have these
properties that their their
form is is fractal you can zoom in and
you can see that there's
complexity at the local scale your your
local computer has
uh has a network and at the global scale
the internet has a network and those
networks have the same sort of topology
it's an engineered human readable scale
invariant
topology and it's it's super powerful
now biological networks have some
interesting similarities to digital
networks
they're they're also scale and variants
so if you zoom into
how a cell works uh it's going to look
similarly in terms of the the math that
describes it to how an entire ecosystem
works
but unlike digital networks biological
networks are self-organized
and they're not engineered they're not
uh human readable they're
they're they're not um we're not capable
of just looking at them and picking out
ah this
this gate here is engineered this way
and this little bit of information there
is designed to flow this
direction there they're just incredibly
complex
they're also dynamic so digital networks
do change but they change
on purpose where engineering the changes
over time
uh biological networks are dynamic
everything about them the structure of
the network
and the function of the network are
linked everything's changing all the
time
and the last really important feature of
biological networks that
distinguishes them from digital networks
is their hyper locality
there's no global communication of
instantness with biological networks
every piece of information has to
has to touch another piece of
information in order to be transmitted
and as we can see with the global
pandemic that can happen and it can
happen
on a shockingly fast time scale but
uh there remains this this need for a
chemical
interaction in order to pass information
from one place to another
what we envision at cardea is uh taking
a technology that we call biology gated
transistors
and connecting these worlds of digital
networks and biological networks
and so on the right here you can see a
couple of different
examples of of what we're getting from
the electronic side of the world
wireless networking personal devices
electronics fabrication
um you know one of the most significant
manufacturing advances that humanity has
ever seen
machine learning an ability to start
growing or understanding beyond what a
person can or any collection of people
can by leveraging software in ways that
that seems you know illogical but
extremely functional on the biology side
we're bringing things that
the hardware and the electronics cannot
match
things like genomics microbiomics
synthetic biology
and proteomics an ability to engineer
highly complex things
not in the same way that is done in the
electronic side where you're building
bottom up
but where you you kind of guide you
evolve and so we've represented that
here the biology side's got these curves
and it's kind of messy
the biology works we're live we know how
we know it's functional
and we're starting to tap into the power
of understanding it through the genomics
and proteomics and
microbiome side but to
to work with something to engineer it to
manufacture it to make it accessible to
everyone in the world that's something
electronics has done
you can find cell phones everywhere in
the world it's amazing but you can't
find
eliza kits you can't find pcr machines
unfortunately
everywhere so
our biological transistors are the are
the
the key the gateway that's going to
connect
the biological world the messy complex
world of biology
to the engineered global world
of electronics and we say
that this begins the era of connected
biology
the era when the local the hyper local
biological networks can be combined
seamlessly with the global digital
networks
and this will allow us to do things like
google
what is my cholesterol and have that
response come up as quickly as asking
what is the capital of kansas
so this is what we envision
this is our vision for the for the for
the world for the future that uh
we're we're enabling an infrastructure
around biology-gated transistors that's
going to directly access biological
information in real time we're not
talking about taking data we're talking
about taking data streams
and this is going to transform the way
we conduct biology
and that's a that's a pun we're making
electronics and
we've got conductors so we're conducting
biology
but it's also about how we change
the action of biology from an
engineering point of view so
uh okay those are really grand claims
and it's a really bold vision and it's
the kind of thing you might have heard
circling around nanotechnology
conferences
for the last 20 years and a big question
has always been
how do you do this is this is this
realistic
so the answer of course is is yes
and let me explain to you how we do it
so we do something
uh um again we've called it a biology
gated transistor
it's a it's a graphene transistor it's
not a digital transistor it's not a
transistor in the
the same sense that your computer runs
on it's more like a a transistor from
the
the radio days uh we we put a voltage on
the gate and the gate changes the
resistance doesn't go on and off
but we see a change in the resistance
with the change in gate
and in our case the gate is biology so
here on the left
you've got um our transistor where we
we've placed our biological capture
mechanism
this could be any sort of active biology
an antibody
a piece of a virus a piece of a cell
a piece of dna and we're looking at the
right on the right side the analytes the
things that that
biology interacts with they bind or they
don't bind
and if something binds and the surface
changes and
that gate changes then our little dial
the base signal goes
from you know white to yellow we see a
change in in the current
through the transistor and i'm going to
get into some more details on that
uh just now
so this is a little bit more uh detail
here
so one thing that happens so we're using
graphene
graphene is a new electronic material
it's different from
silicon it's different from any of the
traditional semiconductors or or even
the metals that you're used to seeing in
electronics
it doesn't have surface oxides
basically what that means is chemically
it doesn't oxidize it doesn't rust
in air doesn't rust in salt water that's
unique
you can take silicon and you put it in
air and it's going to create an oxide
you take any semiconductor you put it in
air
it's going to create an oxide that oxide
is
a chemical barrier between your
electronic part and the rest of the
world
most electronics just does not live in
the world we live in
doesn't coexist with biology graphene
does
so you can take the graphene and you can
attach the biology to it
without anything in between now we do
use a little linker molecule to make
sure we get the right biology in the
right place
but this is a far different scale than
an oxide
the linker molecule and the biology that
we attach are what give
our sensors their specificity so if we
want to look for a specific
antigen in your blood we have to attach
the right antibody
and if that antibody is good we're going
to have a very sensitive sensor and if
that antibody is crummy we're going to
have a crummy sensor
the graphene allows us to detect the
changes happening in the biology
with extraordinary sensitivity but it
doesn't
do anything magic to the biology if the
biology itself is not sensitive
then the sensor as a whole is not
sensitive this is a technology that is a
combination of biological
technology and electronics technology so
you need both to function well
here you see we're a couple little more
diagrams about uh
how the sensor is working we've got two
electrodes
that are controlling the gate so we're
we have kind of a little electrochemical
gate
here um we're encapsulating the
electronics there's there's a lot of
layers that go into this uh into the
manufacture of this but
for a silicon chip for a for a piece of
manufacturer electronics today this is a
very simple design
that said it's one of the more complex
pieces of nanotechnology that are out
there
so we've been at this for a little while
um you know in nanotechnology we've been
we've been making devices like this for
about 20 years
a little more than 10 years uh maybe 15
years that we've been making graphing
devices
but commercially we started in 2013 uh
in
in my garage making the the device you
see on the far left there labeled alpha
it's a well it's the kind of thing you'd
make in your garage
we went from there and the cost for that
one
device was astronomical when you really
think about it it took um
it took months to make one device and
that is typical of the kind of handmade
uh artisanal nanotechnology devices
that have been made in the past the
kinds of things that
i made during my phd project and that
phd students are making all the time
right now
often we get a discount on the real
price because we're trading
that academic achievement for uh for
salary
but if we're going to commercialize
something someone needs to make it and
they need to get
paid a reasonable wage and when you
project things forward it just doesn't
work out
unless you can get into a fad so we go
from the alpha to the first prototype
starting to see how can we get this
onto a printed circuit board and
something that that is a little bit more
scalable
we get to what is called our beta chip
now we have something that is actually
manufactured
in in a wafer scale it's professionally
packaged
and chip packaging is one of those
things that it is extraordinarily
difficult
extraordinarily expensive so
early forays for us into into commercial
packaging
and then finally we get into our first
commercial chip
what we called at the time the test tab
now these are commercial chips that are
sold
we've had customers we've had lots of
successful customers that have done
their own research
published papers starting with that
green first commercial chip that you see
right there
and uh over uh several iterations from
that we went
from the first chip to the second chip
to what we call the first cardea chip
and uh what we mean by that is the first
chip that we
really feel we can make at scale uh with
a level of reproducibility
and quality control that we're ready to
partner with people on large scale
projects
and integration into larger systems it
has a lot to do with cost
the real cost that at the end of the day
after all
overhead and everything else and quality
and the shipping and everything is put
together
moving from you know back in 2013
a real cost of hundreds of thousands of
dollars per chip
to today cost tens of dollars per chip
uh and that just opens up a whole new
world
um of what can be done with these kinds
of
of uh of devices this kind of
nanotechnology
so i wanted to give you guys an example
of the kinds of things that we
we do uh with these sensors and so this
describes one of our early projects with
the cdc
the cdc was one of our earliest partners
they were around for some of those
really early chips that didn't look so
good
and they were big believers in the
vision big believers in the idea of
having something that was electronic
and fast and portable uh and you can
imagine why
and so this particular work we took some
antibodies against
zika that our cdc collaborator had
developed and we attached them to our
chip
and then we put in different types of
blood samples now i i didn't have
actual zika infected blood in my lab
because it's not set up for that
but we were able to take clean blood and
spike in
proteins from zika at a level that would
be
the same that you'd see in actual
infected blood and we'd compare
the the clean blood to the blood that
had the zika virus protein spiked into
it
and when we did that we were able to see
clearly
uh that the the zika virus infected
blood
was was uh gave a much uh different
signal than the healthy blood and you
can see that here in this graph in the
middle
where uh you know the really cool thing
here is that the time axis that x-axis
there
so we we spent five minutes just
calibrating just calibrating in a clean
uh
sample and then we we inject
either a different clean sample or the
infected blood and you can see that
although we took the measurement for for
15 minutes it took just a couple of
minutes before we could clearly see
that there was a huge difference between
the zika protein
spiked blood and the healthy blood uh
now
this was all done on a system you can
see here on the right that
is connected by usb to a to a laptop on
a reader and that that's a
an actual picture that's someone's hand
there it's not a very big thing
it's something that's handheld something
that could be portable um
and so you could see that this is the
first uh effort that we were making to
try and show people that
what we're doing that could have real
impacts
for uh the world of of finding and
diagnosing and monitoring
uh infectious diseases because if you
can get something like this out into the
field where you can do
an assay in five or ten minutes to
detect presence or absence of an
infectious disease
that can make a big difference
so another thing that we we did early on
is we started looking
at some common um inflammation markers
and
inflammation markers like il-6 here
these are the kinds of things that
happen when your immune system is
is ramping up when you're trying to
fight off something it could be an
allergy
could be disease now over expression
of uh some of these markers is is
really a big problem uh with uh for
example
people who have covid19 and so
one of the things we're trying to do
here you know this was this was before
covet 19 we we were simply trying to
show that we could detect
these inflammation markers faster than
you
you could with the standard eliza kit
and that we could meet the same
concentration requirements we could we
get the same limit of detection
and the reason why you want to do that
is uh
if if someone is having an immune
response or an allergic reaction or
or starting to get sick you don't want
to wait wait around hours
for for a labeled test for for
some evolution of a die or to to get
onto a plate reader
you just want to know right now and so
if we can do that electronically locally
wherever the patient is then
that would be great and so what we have
here on the left is the
the data from an il-6 elisa and that's
the standard technology that's used
uh to do these kinds of tests and this
is the
optical adsorb absorbance and this is
taken on a plate reader with
lots of different concentrations log
scale on the x-axis
and um you know the limit of detection
uh for
for this we saw was about let's see i
can't read it
68 picograms per milliliter uh pretty
good
um so we did the same thing now we did
this in
cell growth media so we uh it's a it's a
bit harder than just doing things on a
on uh buffer or in in water this this is
something that has a lot of different
stuff in it it's something that cells
were growing in it has different pieces
of cells and all sorts of stuff in there
and we did this to simulate a real real
world environment
one of the places you might find il-6 is
in cell growth if you're trying to
grow cells for a particular purpose and
you're worried about uh stressing them
out
um and so the limit of detection that we
see is
132 picograms per milliliter now that
that's higher than what we saw in eliza
but the difference is that
one of these is a end point assay it's a
test that you're doing
you're extracting some material you're
sending it off to to a lab bench and
running it through a gamut of different
wash steps and
and die measurements until you get your
result ours is a real-time measurement
we're getting those results in real time
you're not waiting
um you can stick the sense the sensor
right in the media and read
out the data right then so it's
uh it's quite helpful to be able to to
get
these kind of uh very fast uh very
sensitive measurements
um and there's more details on this kind
of measurement in another paper that we
published last year
in scientific reports that shows that
when we're operating in buffer we
actually were
more sensitive than the elisa assay
the last example that i want to show you
is detection of leptin in blood
and this is something that was done with
with some early collaboration at uc
berkeley and also keck graduate
institute
now in this study we were detecting
leptin as part of a study uh
involving aging so uh this was just part
part of the aging study
and uh this was the kind of thing they
they had a little flow-through sensor
that they built on top or a flow-through
channel they were built on top of our
device they were extracting blood
and they were looking for these aging
markers um
they took uh the leptin itself and they
they put the leptin down onto the the
chip
and then they were they're actually
looking not for the leptin but for the
leptin antibody
in the blood and they're trying to track
the concentration of that antibody in
the blood
as part of the study and so you can you
can both take the chip and use it to
detect
a particular antigen like il-6 or the
zika
virus protein or you can flip it around
you can put the antigen down
and you can look for the antibody
against it and that way you could you
can see that
uh you could look for something like do
have you developed an immune response to
something
now you could imagine hey um
have i had covet 19 have i had this
strain of covet 19 have i had
this year's flu yet those kinds of
things could be
answered with this kind of test that was
also published
2018 in lab on a chip
last example here uh and this is the one
that uh probably has gotten the most
attention
uh for what we've done and that is um
now the most biologically complex
measurement that we've done and that's
uh crispr
on the chip so crispr is a is a
combination of proteins
and rna that are are used together
to detect dna and um we did this
also in collaboration with uc berkeley
and keck graduate institute
we did detection of dna specific
detection of dna without amplification
that's something that's really important
because amplification causes a lot of
errors and can cause a lot of problems
it's one of the big issues with with how
do you
identify um a rapidly mutating virus for
example
sometimes the selection of the
amplification probe can
can really determine the efficacy of
your test
now we have an ability to do
multiplexing of lots of different tests
across one chip we can look at lots of
different dna strands
um simultaneously uh there's there's not
a necessity for us to
be limited to one probe or um or a few
probes
we're limited only by uh the the
aggressiveness in manufacturing that we
pursue
um the electronics industry the the
chips in your computer
they have a lot of transistors on them
we can pack a lot of transistors and a
lot of sensors onto a chip
so let's talk about this specific assay
we take
the cas9 protein that's part of the
crispr complex we immobilize that onto
the chip
then we take um a search query in the
form of
a an rna sequence and that search query
rna sequence is in
is then loaded into the cas9 protein
which is already on
our chip and that forms a crispr complex
now in this paper we used dcas9 meaning
that it was it was cas9 that did not
cut the dna after it found it it just
searched for the dna
if it found the dna that we had coded it
to find
it would lock down and stop just hold it
in place
and what we do is we'd wash over genomic
dna
all the dna in a sample everything
let this little biological machine
search through that dna for the match
and if it found the match it would lock
it down then we'd rinse off
all the dna that wasn't bound to the
chip and
if the dna that we were searching for
was found we would get a big response
and if the dna we were searching for
was not found we would get a small
response
this searching took about an hour
so sometimes we could go as low as half
an hour but
but about an hour to do this entire
search operation
if we're trying to do that
computationally if we're trying to do
that via electronics and software
it takes a lot longer to search an
entire genome
than an hour when you're talking about
sequencing or something like that
so this is not a sequencing technology
it's a dna detection technology
but it does dna detection faster than
any combination of other
uh electronics that we we can find and
it's because we're leveraging
the the power of this biological machine
the crispr complex and this all makes
sense the crispr complexes
is a bacteria's immune system it's its
purpose is to rapidly search out
dna that might might be part of a virus
and to cut it up
so if you're looking for dna that's part
of a virus doesn't make sense
to use the biological machines that
that do that so here on the right you
can see
uh the the cover of nature biomedical
engineering
a paper um that all of this data is from
and then the the key piece of data from
that paper which is we were able to take
some samples uh that were both healthy
and
and not healthy for duchenne muscular
dystrophy and uh duchenne muscular
dystrophy is a lack of a gene
in a particular set of or a lack of an
exon in a particular gene
so a particular set of dna is missing
and
what you can see here and these graphs
all these bar graphs the gray
graphs are either healthy samples or
samples that are
are known to be missing a different gene
than the particular one we were looking
for here
and we can see that in all of those
samples we find
the the entire gene the all the exons
that we were looking for
but in those blue samples those are the
ones that were that were missing
exon 51 out of this gene and we see that
those samples
give us a lower result meaning the dna
did not stick to the surface
it was not locked down by the crispr
complex
when it did its little search mechanism
so
uh these four examples give you an idea
of the the breadth
of of sensing that we can do the
different kinds of things where we can
we can take antibodies we can search for
viral proteins
we can search for immune responses like
il-6
we can search for antibodies like that
your immune system has
generated against proteins and we can
search directly for dna
through the crispr complex so um
something that's that's kind of
interesting now switching gears and
talking a bit about covid
um when you have a when you have a
patient and you're looking at
uh viral load and whether you have
symptoms
uh is it is it sufficient to just say
how much virus do i have on me
um to know whether or not or sorry is it
sufficient to say am i symptomatic do i
feel bad
or do i feel healthy because you could
feel perfectly healthy and still be out
there infecting people
so wouldn't it be nice to be able to
know that you actually
you're shedding virus you're shedding
cove 19.
and so you can see here in this in this
graph
whether you're symptomatic or
asymptomatic you've got the same amount
of virus coming out
so uh a test that was able to detect
um rapidly and kind of in your hands
whether or not you're shedding virus
would would be invaluable to knowing
whether you should stay home
or whether you should now be allowed to
go outside and
interact with the rest of the world
similarly
we talked a little bit about this on the
il-6 slide the
the inflammation response um i think
this is from sars one
uh the inflammation response uh in in
uh in at-risk people in in
in this case aged versus young uh people
um is heightened incredibly
uh when when you're uh infected again
this is with sars
cov1 um but we would expect the same
thing
with the the current uh pandemic they're
they're
related diseases uh so you can imagine a
test
that looked for how what is the the
ratio of
il-6 to ccl2 or
are you are you producing il-8 or not
these kinds of ideas these kinds of
tests of looking at your immune response
could tell you are you are you on the
way towards
a serious infection or are you going to
have a mild infection
because uh it's the that really hard um
immune response that's causing a lot of
damage to patients
this would allow doctors to more um more
quickly triage people
if if it looks like you're gonna have a
mild uh case of the disease you should
just
go home and rest but if you're on track
to to
to need a ventilator to to need
intensive care
let's get that care early and uh
and prevent the worst stages of the
disease if possible
so what we're thinking we could do for
something like covid19 or
specifically for coven19 should we get
the opportunity in the
partnerships to do it would be to
improve the diagnostic testing
capabilities both
directly detecting the virus detecting
your immune response detecting
your immunity and we can do this by
having a highly reconfigurable
device for single or multiple analytes
something that could be available for
single use um
local portable use or for high
throughput testing
something that is seamlessly transfers
the electronic results to the cloud
which which really is the only way we
can effectively
track these kinds of infections this is
the vision of how our technology
can be used in something like this
now when you look at the technology here
part of the
advantage of using a transistor-based
approach a direct detection approach a
data streaming rather than
end point approach is that it is
applicable in all of these different
areas whether you're talking about
at-home testing
point of care testing molecular testing
immunoassays or central lab testing
doing it all on the same platform allows
you to streamline
your assay development allows you to
streamline data analysis and comparison
of apples to apples
um in different locations and in
and from uh different uh communities
different points of view different users
so the the um factors that go into
to allowing us to do this is that that
we're we're fast
multi-analyte multi-form factor
kind of technology this chip can be used
anywhere you could put it it could be
used in handheld it could be some robot
it's quantitative it could be used for
biosurveillance and it's rapidly
reconfigurable meaning you can put down
different antibodies you can put down
different proteins
you can program the crispr complex with
different rnas
you just have to make the chips and then
program them before you use them
this is a picture that we've made our
our idea of what multi-analyte testing
should look like
you've got a small reader that handles
all of the
um operations of the test
a swab system that uses perhaps saliva
perhaps mucus
and is and is uh incorporated into
a cartridge that houses the chip the
cartridge goes into the reader and it
reads out whatever test
that cartridge has been biologically
encoded to make and the whole thing
could be
communicating with a cell phone via
bluetooth or
via wi-fi those kinds of things because
we're rooted in electronics those are
easy to do
the reconfigurability of the biology
that's the hard part
the multiplexing from say 16 elements to
thousands of elements that's hard to do
but that could be done on something this
small this compact and this easy to use
so some of the things we've talked about
doing
using a nasal swab to detect viral rna
to detect your personal um
viral load are you safe to go out into
the society or not
we've looked at doing a multiplexed
serological assay
what strains of
sars cove two have you been exposed to
and do you have you developed immunity
to
if you know that you're immune that
means that you can you can also
go out um safely at least for yourself
um now the kind of things that we're
talking about from when it comes to
sample type right we've talked about
blood we've talked about serum
saliva we can use all of these different
things these these are
are probably multiple different types of
of uh
devices uh we can do the sample
preparation
off chip so um there's lots of different
ways of doing sample prep that's not
what we're good at we're good at the
chips
and we can do integration integration of
the sample prep into the cartridge
if necessary we talked about all the
different
form factors i didn't show them to you
so here this is an example of it
on the left a 256 plex chip so something
with 256 sensors on it
that's that's more than we currently use
in our commercial chips in the middle is
that that
picture of the handheld reader that
we're envisioning and on the right is a
is a photograph
of a robot that we use right now um to
do
it's not um high throughput in the sense
of pharmaceutical testing but it's high
throughput
in the terms of how many chips we can
get through per day
uh we can we can set this up to do up to
thousands of chips per day
this whole thing works because we've got
one chip we've got one set of software
we've got one way of analyzing the data
everything goes to the cloud our
philosophy here is that
you want to separate as much as you can
any um
uh medical expertise uh epidemiological
expertise
uh necessary from from the the local on
the ground people
because you're not always gonna have
that available so if you can get the
data up
into the cloud and out to the internet
as quickly as possible into the hands of
the people who can do the most with it
you're going to be doing the most good
so that's the approach for
the current disease the other thing is
that as we're doing assay development as
um as viruses uh change as as
the next pandemic comes we can mine that
data in the cloud
to go back into the robot to try out
new approaches to the assay to figure
out
how could we have improved this assay
done over here
in another country um and create
something we call the excel solver for
system biology a closed loop
of fast electronic sensing and
cloud-based data and analytics with
something that's
incorporating machine learning or ai if
you will to find the best approach
to taking data the best approach to
processing and performing assay
now we're not a company that's going to
be able to do all of this
we're a company that that looks to
partners for a big part of it
um and uh you know there's people out
there that are better
uh at sample handling at engineering at
software
and really we're good at the chips the
nano technology
so uh when we go to partner with people
what you get is you get this
you get the chip you get the chip
technology we're looking for people who
who can um work with us at the small
scale the large scale
who can bring their own technology and
allow us to um
to spread it out to the rest of our
partners and and we're also looking for
people that
maybe they just they just want us to
handle everything and we'll find other
partners to
to get the job done um but there's lots
of advantages to working with us
uh i talked a lot today this this talk
was focused on on infectious disease
um in terms of application but there's a
lot of different areas that we look at
and this is this is one of our business
slides this is not
not a slide i typically give this is the
universe of addressable market
opportunities um we're looking
across the board everything that we've
talked about in the last 20 years in
nanotechnology is something that
we hope to positively impact uh in the
next few years
and we've already got partners in a lot
of these different areas
not to say that we can't use more in all
of them as well
so i hope that through this talk i've
given you some idea of what we're trying
to do how we're trying to approach
our responsibility to to husband or
technology
into a form that helps helps the world
with the current crisis
helps the world with the next crisis and
and gave you some idea of what it is
that you could do to help us out
we think that really biology
is technology uh we've taken um
you know since 2013 those are those
early ugly chips
uh we've made a lot of progress on
manufacturing engineering understanding
the design space
that we're working within now with the
right partners
we can really build an infrastructure
that changes the way
we uh we all approach biology we all
approach
the kinds of challenges that we have
literally today
with that i'd like to thank you